it's it's very easy to be seduced by
doing things efficiently trying to do a
lot of things well I don't believe
that's the most important thing the most
important thing is picking the right
things to do in the first place and
that's being effective versus just being
efficient so within a start-up its
success I don't think it's measured by
how many things you can do at once its
measured by how effectively you're able
to pick the one or two things into the
highest priority and there's always
going to be a seduction to get
distracted and focus on twenty things at
once and the most effective
entrepreneurs I know are very good at
focusing on one or two things and either
eliminating the rest with delegating to
other people or outsourcing it so it's
not done within the team but it's
actually two third parties so
entrepreneurs tend to miscalculate is
everything what I mean by that is
optimism has a place but I think even
more so for the first time entrepreneur
you need to be pragmatically pessimistic
what I mean by that is you need to
define all the worst-case scenarios in
terms of financial loss time loss etc
look at what you will learn if that
happens and accept and come to terms
with that before you ever start if you
don't do that and you go straight into
battling the world trying to conquer the
world with rose-colored glasses on the
first time you hit a major hiccup you're
gonna become really demoralized and you
will quit so optimism all that rah rah
rah
that's awesome but you need to hope for
the best and prepare for the worst
before you ever get started I always
recommend that you just watch two
amazing clips from Tim Ferriss take the
next three minutes to sit quietly and
think about how you can apply them to
your business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]